wenn das internet eine medizin wäre
stünde im werbeprospekt es macht uns
gescheiter vertreibt die langeweile
vermehrt unsere sozialkontakte und
stärkt die demokratie
und weil das alles stimmt liest niemand
gern die kleingedruckte packungsbeilage
die vor dem gefährlichen nebenwirkungen
waren wie die digitale total vernetzung
den menschen verändert das besprechen
wir mit miriam meckel die als
kommunikations professorin an der uni st
gallen und chefredaktorin der deutschen
wirtschaftswoche
die digitalen wunderwaffen souverän zu
führen weiß aber gleichzeitig warnt wenn
die computer erst das letzte bisschen
zufall aus unserem leben hinaus
gerechnet haben dann wird in diesem
leben nichts mehr sein wie es sagt
miriam meckel herzlich willkommen
dankeschön
was würden sie verband auf eine einsame
insel mitnehmen ein kindle mit dem man
sich alle bücher der welt herunterladen
kann einen laptop auf dem man sich
ausschließlich die news des tages heran
googeln kann oder ein handy auf dem man
aber nur skypen oder telefonieren kann
eine schwierige frage am liebsten würde
ich natürlich einen menschen mitnehmen
weil ich glaube zufällig das wäre das
beste aber dann wäre es keine einsame
insel mehr
also ich wähle ich wähle das ebook dass
das kindle um alle bücher der welt bei
mir zu haben und ließen mal in ruhe noch
zu lesen und verzichten dafür darauf
einen richtigen menschen mindestens
anrufen zu können
ja telefonieren ist nicht mehr in dem
ranking müsste da mein start sein und
sonst dann lieber die weltliteratur
nochmal durch studieren aber kann sagen
im richtigen leben ist sie lieben all
diese spielzeuge und super greife ich
liebe sie ich habe sie auch und ich
nutze sie wirklich sehr intensiv deshalb
also ich glaube bevor man mich mit nur
einem gerät auf eine einsame insel
bekommen würde das das wäre schon da
müsste man mir großen zwang antun und
wahrscheinlich denken wie auch immer
über seine situation er nach dass es
schön ist sich vorzustellen
mal für eine weile auf einer einsamen
insel
und da alle bücher der welt lesen zu
können oder damit beginnen zu können
aber wenn es dann wirklich so wäre es
glaube ich ganz schnell ganz schön ganz
schön schlimm
ja ich habe ihn jetzt ein ebook in das
gedankenexperiment hinein geschummelt
im richtigen leben lesen sie auch noch
bücher sie schreiben bücher aus papier
lesen sie auch bücher ausprobieren ich
lese auch nicht aus papier er also dass
das ist schon so ich lese allerdings
ganz viel tatsächlich auf den kindle
weil ich viel unterwegs bin und man auf
diesem kleinen gerät mit dem man mit
licht nachts überall lesen kann und was
einfach sehr praktisch ist so viel hat
dass das schätze ich sehr
ich kaufe mir aber häufig dann bücher
gehe ich auf dem kindle gelesen habe
tatsächlich nochmal in als papierausgabe
irgendwie ins regal zu stellen weil es
irgendwie eine beziehung gibt zwischen
zwischen dem sehen des buches und dem
erinnern dessen was da drin ist und das
ist im digitalen medien bisschen anders
da haben sie alles das ist alles
irgendwie verschwunden während ich so
ein buch anfassen kann und auch weiß wo
habe ich was mag ihre tour habe ich mir
was angestrichen wo habe ich eine ecke
dran gemacht und mich daran zu erinnern
das war oben rechts oben links das ist
dann schon unterschied die generation
der kids kann man sagen auch ihre
studierenden die sind dauernd in den
sozialen medien unterwegs wie ist das
bei der professorin
ich bin auch relativ viel unterwegs
wobei nicht nur in sozialen medien also
ich bin schon auf facebook ich bin bei
linkedin zum beispiel das sind so
vernetzungs elemente man kriegt gute
gute inhaltliche tipps gute
informationen gute hinweise da ich
twittere ab und zu das auch ein
interessantes informationsmedium aber
ich bin natürlich auch ansonsten im
internet wirklich viel unterwegs weil
dort eine menge informationen zu finden
ist die ich dann auch nutzen um daraus
beruflich etwas zu machen im
journalistischen alltag auch zu sammeln
für irgendwann mal wieder ein buch oder
so das ist schon ein ein quell der
information der der meinung
der einschätzung den ich wirklich
großartig würde ich muss halt ich finde
diese quelle also man spürte sie sind
eine kompetente und leidenschaftliche
nutzerin dieser neuen technologischen
möglichkeiten und wir wollen ja ja und
auch nicht wie die maschinenstürmer
aufführen die im 19 jahrhundert wie die
heimarbeiter damals die tuchmacher und
so die dann die mechanischen webstühlen
kaputt geschlagen haben das wollen wir
nicht und hier gegen alles digitale vom
leder ziehen aber zu beginn möchte ich
trotzdem die ganz dunklen seiten des
internets mal richtig ins visier nehmen
man kann doch sagen nebst allem anderen
ist das world wide web manchmal so eine
richtige dreck leute bekommen sie viel
hass mails und solches zeug hat die
kriege ich schon ja also es gibt eine
menge an botschaften bekommen
erschreckender weise zum teil mit vollem
namen und voller adresse des absenders
darunter wo man sich schon gewundert wie
menschen auf so eine idee kommen können
so was zu schreiben und fließt das an
ihnen ab wie sonst aus oder trifft es
nein das wäre wirklich das wäre gelogen
wenn ich das sagen würde das trifft
schon jetzt nicht weil ich irgendwie
dann angst bekommen also also wenn
jemand schreibe ich hoffe dass sie heute
abend in auf der dunklen straße in einem
tunnel jemanden begegnen dann ist das in
satz wo ich denke ich habe jetzt nicht
angst dass mir das wirklich passiere
aber so was wie das das wort geschrieben
dass noch die harmlosere variante von
dingen die geschrieben werden ich habe
schon ich habe schon dann ein unwohlsein
weil ich mich frage wo kommt das
eigentlich her und was was für ein bild
haben die menschen über mich oder was
haben sie auch für den umgang mit
anderen menschen für ein bild das sie
sowas schreiben können das also dass das
ist eine entgrenzung mit der ich mich
schwer tue ich kann auch wirklich eine
wut entbrannte e mail schreiben ich kann
mich dafür aber auch entschuldigen
kurze zeit später aber eher so was zu
schreiben ist dann schon noch mal ein
anderer anderer zugang kommt das immer
etwa gleich dosiert oder wissen sie wenn
ich das thema anfasse dann kommt die
welle
ja ich weiß wer immer in die welle
kommen ja also die welle kommt im rahmen
der
deutschen öffentlichkeit derzeit beim
thema alternative für deutschland afd
das ist ein typischer wellen macher für
solche reaktionsmuster es gibt auch das
thema flüchtlinge ist das ja auch zum
teil verbunden ist ein thema wo solche
wellen kommen und es hat glaube ich
immer damit zu tun dass das eine form
von von grundannahme damit schwingt
derjenigen die solche solche
wutentbrannten oder hasserfüllten e
mails oder oder nachrichten schreiben
dass sie dass sie belogen werden dass
ihnen nicht die wahrheit gesagt wird
dass irgendwie etwas nicht mehr stimmt
in unserer öffentlichen diskussion und
das glaube ich habe tatsächlich sehr
viel mit dem internet zu tun und einem
mechanismus den wir ja seit jahren schon
mal immer so ein bisschen diskutiert
haben aber der der eigentlich nicht so
richtig durchgekommen ist jetzt besser
durchgekommen und jetzt kann man sagen
das was unter dem namen filter blase
oder echo kammer bekannt geworden ist
das merken wir glaube ich gerade und das
ist ein phänomen wo eigentlich die
tatsache dass wir im internet mit mit
personalisierten informationen aus
auseinandersetzen müssen uns dass das so
zu sagen hier zugespitzt wird das heißt
wenn ich versuche ja oder wenn ich bei
amazon was kaufe oder wenn ich sozusagen
auf facebook bin rechnet der algorithmus
hier aus was was mache ich da eigentlich
immer anguckt was mag bergab und jetzt
nah und das sind die politischen
präferenzen die produkt präferenzen die
freizeit präferenz das kann man alles
wunderschön zu einem päckchen
zusammenschnüren und dann weiß man was
man ihnen für informationen aus rechnet
und ihnen zur verfügung stellt und wenn
man das im politischen bereich anschaut
dann kommen wir halt da hin dass wir
eigentlich immer mehr dass das bekommen
was wir schon mögen und eh schon gesucht
haben und die welt sich die sich daraus
ergibt ist eine die sehr
individualisiert wird wo ich das gefühl
habe ich habe eigentlich immer recht ja
weil die resonanz aus dem internet ist
immer eine bestätigung für meine
position nennt man in der wissenschaft
konfirmation bestätigungs problem und
dann ist alles was an von anderen seiten
kommen von alternativen kommt ist
plötzlich
was verdächtig auch das ist fast
verdächtig er nach dem motto da wurde
uns etwas falsches eingeschleust weil
alle anderen denken doch so wie ich und
der mechanismus den so empfinde ich es
haben wir im moment in der öffentlichen
diskussion ganz stark im internet noch
stärker aber er prägt inzwischen
eigentlich die gesamte öffentliche
diskussion an vielen stellen und das hat
schon was mit der digitalisierung und
vernetzung zu tun hat so viele
menschenleben dann nur noch in ihre
filter blase glauben sie haben recht
alle anderen sind schlecht und auf dem
falschen dampfer und dann kommen diese
fluten von hass reaktionen die haben ja
einen fachausdruck der also ebenso
bildhaft die unappetitlich ist das heißt
ja dann shitstorm man will sich gar
nicht zu konkret vorstellen was in der
luft herum fliegt exkremente wirklich
wirklich übel und ist auch so dann diese
diese shitstorm sind übel und unter
genau diesem titel shitstorm widmet das
schweizer fernsehen am kommenden
mittwoch um 22 uhr 55 auf sf1 diesen
phänomenen eine eindrückliche
dokumentation und um die bedrohlichkeit
solcher hass werden hier noch mehr
spürbar zu machen habe ich eine szene
aus diesem topf film shitstorm hier
mitgebracht
bianca echtermeyer fand es lustig dass
erwachsene männer auf skateboards durch
die gegend fahren und schrieb im
november 2012 eine glosse in brigitte de
etwas überspitzt aber harmlos würde man
meinen
die skater communitys aber fanden es
überhaupt nicht lustig
gegen aus der mittagspause
zurückgekommen habe unter dem artikel
geguckt dass man schon 1000 kommentare
darunter was sehr viel war für damalige
verhältnisse vor allen dingen in dem
moment habe ich halt gewusst das ist
nichts was normal ist also das geht über
das was ich vorher kannte einfach total
hinaus ein echter marias glosse
erwachsene männer die skateboard fahren
steig ab man entfachte sich ein
shitstorm wie ihn das deutsche web noch
nicht erlebt hatte
es kam nicht ein kommentar wie
normalerweise so in kurzer wir das
einkommen einer kommt der nächste
konnten ist das war wirklich so ist kam
wulffs kam wirklich 100 kommentare pro
sekunde es rasselte auf uns ein
auf facebook und twitter kommentar
seiten blogs und auf eigens geschaffenen
website hagelte es beschimpfungen
sexistische hass kommentare
morddrohungen und vergewaltigungs
aufrufe noch am selben abend verkauften
online-shops t shirts buttons tassen und
pullover mit der aufschrift love bianca
unzählige fotomontagen wurden gebastelt
um die journalistin öffentlich
niederzumachen
wenn man auf einmal so im mittelpunkt
steht und so in ein so einen hass
mittelpunkt das war tatsächlich so wie
man sich vielleicht früher so eine
hexenverfolgungen also was vorstellen
konnte dass man auf einmal doch zum
scheiterhaufen steht und von allen
seiten kommt an und dann ist es
eigentlich auch egal ob es virtuell ist
oder ob es real ist
miriam meckel was macht die menschen im
netz so brutal
ich glaube die die entgrenzung im
wortsinne zwischen dem verfassen der
botschaft und dem dem senden der
botschaft weil wenn wir so
gegenübersitzen und ich würde jetzt eine
hasstirade hier lostreten abgesehen
davon dass ich keinen grund dazu habe
aber nehmen wir das mal an es ist
natürlich eine ganz andere situation
weil ich mich mit ihrer reaktion
auseinandersetzen muss weil ich damit
rechnen muss dass die sofort kommt weil
auch wir natürlich als menschen soziale
wesen sind irgendwie spüren wenn der
andere anfängt zu reagieren und das ist
ja eine form von kontrollfunktion die
dann einsetzt normalerweise wo man eben
mit umgehen kann
im internet ist das ja nicht so also ein
kommentar zu posten auf einen artikel
wie das der kollegin geschehen ist das
geht einfach ganz schnell ja ich
schreibe das runter in meinem ersten
wutausbruch und dann brauche ich einen
klick oder eine berührung des
bildschirms und schon ist das ding weg
also das ist eine form von distanz die
da vorhanden ist die zu einer totalen
distanzlosigkeit im sozialen umgang
miteinander führt in ihrem kleinen aber
schönen buch wir verschwinden der mensch
im digitalen zeitalter steht ganz vorn
ein zitat aus der new york times und der
warnow facelift die augen sind noch da
big brother wahrscheinlich und die
gesichter sind weg ist ist das das
problem dass man kein gesicht mehr
gegenüber
das ist das problem aber das zitat
übrigens um das einzuordnen ist aus
einem ganz anderen zusammenhang der aber
hier auch passt das zitat ist aus einem
artikel der new york times zu einem
drohnenangriff der usa in afghanistan
und beobachter der szenerie nach dem
drohnenangriff haben eben das
beschrieben dass ein wörtliches zitat
eines beobachters
wir haben die augen gefunden aber die
gesichter waren weg aber physisch das
war physisch gemeint es ist aber mit
hervor ich deshalb habe ich rein
geschrieben sehr interessant weil es
natürlich genau so passt also gleiche
mechanismus eine drohne abzuschießen die
dann zb
ein haus aus luft in dem menschen sind
an einem bildschirm ist ein ein anderer
akt als hinzugehen in einem realen krieg
und einen angriff beispielsweise als
fußtruppe zu laufen gegen dieses haus wo
ich möglicherweise die opfer die gleich
sterben werden sehen muss vorher noch
das ist also die gleiche distanz und
distanzlosigkeit problematik die wir in
der kommunikation auch haben daran denkt
vielleicht manch ein wutbürger gar nicht
der am stammtisch sagt ja dieser obama
gilt alle menschen damit seinen thron
und denkt nicht der wutbürger dass wenn
er einfach so zeugs ins internet hinein
kommt dass das eine ziemlich eigentliche
sache ist ja es kann halt es kann
unglaublich verletzten und jemanden auch
richtig so zu sagen ja ich glaube sogar
psychisch krank machen also wenn man
einen solchen sturm ausgesetzt ist und
zum objekt des hasses einer einer ganzen
netzgemeinde wird dann ist das ja schon
eine ziemlich harte situation
das interessante was was ich erlebt habe
hier ist ich mache das manchmal so dass
ich dann antworte also wenn jemand
wirklich mit mit namen und adresse
schreibt was wirklich häufig passiert
dann antworte ich darauf wenn ich das
gefühl habe hier hat es sinn das mal zu
versuchen und in der reaktion ist ganz
oft so dass die menschen dann wirklich
zurückschrecken also da kommt jetzt was
hoch da setzt sich jemand den ich dann
mal kurz aggressiv angegangen bin mit
meiner botschaft auseinander und dann
dann gibt's rückzug meistens gibt
rückzug und eine relativierung und dann
wird gesagt
dann habe ich mich vielleicht auch
vertan und so habe ich ja nicht gemalt
und es tut mir leid es gibt auch eine
entschuldigung
deshalb lohnt sich das auch wenn das
sehr viel zeit kostet das zu machen im
einzelnen bei einem schutzraum derart
ist es deutlich schwieriger damit
umzugehen weil das eine dynamik hat eine
schnelligkeit im internet hat mit der
man dann kaum mitkommt
weil das schaukelt sich natürlich dann
hoch jeder noch böser noch dümmer könnte
man sagen irgendwann droht in unserer
gesellschaft die die herrschaft der
idioten und dummköpfe polterer ich hoffe
es nicht dass das so ist aber ich glaube
schon dass das was so passiert anlass
genug ist darüber nachzudenken was man
auch in der in der öffentlichen
diskussion übrigens auch bei medien
ich denke im moment sehr viel darüber
nach ende
muss um zu versuchen überzeugungsarbeit
dafür zu leisten dass hier nicht gelogen
wird
der galt die ganze debatte die
insbesondere in deutschland jetzt extrem
hoch gekommen ist mit dem furchtbaren
begriff der lügen presse ist ist
schrecklich aber sie ist natürlich
trotzdem auch ein anreiz oder sollte ein
anreiz sein sich mit der eigenen rolle
auseinander zu setzen und sich zu fragen
wo sind wir vielleicht auch arrogant ja
und wir wo achten wir nicht genug darauf
dass wir unsere positionen erklären
müssen und dass wir wirklich begründen
müssen mit fakten warum wir zu dem
ergebnis kommen dass das sind schon
diskussionen die wir glaube ich führen
müssen und dazu kommt hat eine gewisse
distanz die viele spüren von der
gesellschaft in der sie leben der
distanz zu der politik die sie
eigentlich repräsentieren soll
und dann entsteht forciert durch diese
mechanismen im internet über die wir
reden eine eine hohe unzufriedenheit
einen glauben an seine
verschwörungstheorie dass man eigentlich
betrogen wird was immer auch passiert
und dann ist der nährboden für solche
schützt uns und für solche wellen
wirklich gemacht und damit aus dem sich
auseinanderzusetzen und da auch etwas
gegen zu setzen ist glaube ich schon ein
angebot derzeit im moment und jetzt wo
sie als professorin wieder zurück in die
praxis gehen als chefredaktorin der
wirtschaftswoche versuchen sie dort den
dialog mit den usern zu führen oder ist
das illusorisch letztlich es ist nicht
illusorisch es ist aber unmöglich den
dialog flächendeckend zu führen also was
wir machen ist dass wir wirklich schauen
regelmäßig leserinnen und leser
einzuladen
auch bewusst einzuladen um solche
schwierigen themen anzusprechen dann in
kontakt zu kommen und das bringt ganz
viel essens lernt man viel über die
bedenken und die sorgen die die haben
und die möglicherweise auch grund für
solche wutausbrüche sein können und zum
anderen ist das auch eben ein reality
check würde ich sagen ein abgleich mit
der wirklichkeit unserer arbeit und
ansonsten ist es natürlich so dass die
die schwierigste frage ist wie geht man
mit kommentierungen um
es gibt inzwischen nur noch wenige
medien die das ganze freizulassen
auch lange darüber nachgedacht und man
ist dort ja dann schnell an den punkt wo
man sich auch fragen muss was verträgt
sich eigentlich mit unseren qualitativen
und publizistischen anspruch und hass
kommentare ausländerfeindliche
kommentare antisemitische kommentare
abgesehen von der tatsache dass sie
strafrechtlich relevant sind ab einem
bestimmten punkt vertragen sich damit
nicht und damit muss man umgehen und ich
habe da auch eine sehr dezidierte
position dass ich sage wie offenen
fenster wo wir diese diskussion zu
lassen aber ich sehe mich nicht in der
verpflichtung auch ein unglaubliches
budget bereitzustellen um mit den hut
attacken von menschen umzugehen die
komplett unmotiviert ja oft dann
daherkommen
das können wir nicht und das ist glaube
ich auch eine entwicklung die im
internet inzwischen stattgefunden hat
das so die hoffnung wir haben die große
demokratische plattform in der wir wie
in der griechischen agora miteinander
auf virtueller basis diskutieren und
heraus kommt immer etwas zur
verbesserung unserer demokratie zur
verbesserung unseres staatswesens zur
verbesserung unserer wirtschaft diese
vorstellung hat sich inzwischen als
relativ naiv und unrealistisch
herausgestellt und deshalb da ändert
sich was im moment und wir haben gesagt
also dass eine schattenseite des world
wide web das hier diese hass wellen
heran fluten ist es letztlich wirklich
einen unterschied wenn leute die man
auch zu den good guys zu den guten im
netz hält die organisationen wie haben
das international greenpeace wwf von so
eine kampagne lancieren die dann auch
wie eine welle über nestlé oder
irgendeinen großen multinationalen
konzern hereinbricht ist es dort ok und
beim gut bürger nicht oder sollten alle
das nicht machen na also dass das wäre
schon mal ein ziemlich bigotte haltung
wenn das dort okay ist bei den angels
und bei denen die vermeintlich
selbsternannte auf der guten seite
stehen und die anderen dürfen uns nicht
das ist genau die die begründung für die
die zum beispiel ein wutbürger
vermutlich heranziehen würde und die
dürfen ist wir dürfen es nicht es gibt
eine einteilung eine moralische zwischen
gut und schlecht in der gesellschaft die
irgendwelche menschen vornehmen die dazu
gar nicht legitimiert sind also medien
sind dazu auch nicht legitimiert
insofern
dass das ist nicht der fall und wenn man
so ein beispiel nimmt die greenpeace
kampagne gegen nestlé im hinblick auf
das palmöl in kitkat vor einigen jahren
einer gorilla finger in eine packung
steht ein blutender korea finger in
einer packung in denen der der
schokoladenriegel freudige reinweißen
wollte also dass das war sehr wirksam
aber es wird natürlich immer dazu dass
die differenzierte diskussion über ein
phänomen eigentlich an den punkt stoppt
deshalb kampagne ist ist nicht
informations orientiert sondern will
agenda setting betreiben wir themen
setzen und auch interpretationen von von
themen setzen im amerikanischen würde
man da sagen es geht um den spin ja den
richtigen dreh den ein thema kriegen
soll
und das finde ich ist das ist okay dass
das passiert jeder will seine themen
rüberbringen aber wenn das das
grundmuster einer gesellschaftlichen
diskussion wird ist es schlecht und
deshalb gilt eher weniger davon würde
uns überall nutzen glaube ich man könnte
den endlos anfalls zugute halten dass
sie nicht im schatten operieren die
schreiben dann irgendwann darunter den
namen der irgendwann hilft dass er
wissen oder erst wenn es immer gleich
runter gehen würde aber es hilft
zumindest schon mal also aber sagen wir
diese dinge heften wir mal ab als echte
oder sagen wir sehr sichtbare
schattenseiten und jetzt ist eben ganz
spannenden ihren allen ihren letzten
büchern eigentlich machen sie diese
analyse dass an dem internet viel gutes
ist und wenn man aber noch genauer
hinschaut was sie dann sehr scharf tun
dann sieht man auch gefahren und
zunächst einmal aber fand ich eine ganz
interessante passagen irgendwo wo sie
sagen
irgendwie erinnert das internet an die
ideale maschine wie sie karl marx im
neunzehnten jahrhundert einmal
geschrieben habt er hat ja gesagt das
reich der freiheit beginnt erst wenn das
reich der notwendigkeit überwunden ist
wenn der mensch nicht mehr arbeiten muss
und so und da fand ich total spannend
sie machen einen vergleich zwischen
dieser marken vision der gesellschaft wo
die perfekte maschine uns alle fit und
unsere bedürfnisse befriedigt und im
internet zeichnen sie das mal nach marx
und internet ja da kommt man zunächst
nicht darauf dass das zusammenhängen
könnte aber aber es hängt zusammen und
ist um das mal vorzuschieben eigentlich
ein beweis dafür dass wir gar nicht über
gut oder böse reden sondern dass wir
eigentlich bei abbyy ganz vielen
technologischen entwicklungen darüber
reden wie gesellschaftliche prozesse
abläufe funktionen sich verändern und
das wäre meine vorstellung von einer
diskussion im sinne einer einer wirklich
konstruktiven gesellschaftskritik dass
man einfach versucht auszuloten welche
szenarien gibt es welche optionen gibt
es ohne dass man das moralisch bewertet
erstmal na das kann man auch dann tun im
zweiten schritt aber erst mal geht es um
die analyse und was ich gefunden habe
als ich nicht ein bisschen mit der frage
wie wie scheint jetzt auf die nächste
die nächste wirtschaftsordnung des
digitalen kapitalismus oder wie
entwickelt sich die auseinandergesetzt
habe bin ich eben auf diesen text
gestoßen das ist ein textfragment das
überliefert ist von karl marx aus dem
jahre 1957 58 über die die ideale
maschine und diese ideale maschine
stellt sich marx ist eine solche vor die
immer weiter läuft aus ganz vielen
organismen zusammengesetzt immer weiter
läuft und nichts mehr kostet und hat
natürlich nicht als internet gedacht er
hat an dieser software gesagt der
menschen gedacht an eine universelle
verbindung von menschen die alle
sozusagen automatisch immer weiter
prozessieren und das irgendwann dann ein
technologie übergeben können das werden
dann eher die webstühle zur magischer
zeit gewesen und nicht der computer aber
das läuft dann immer weiter und wir
können uns als menschen auch ein stück
von dem was uns alltäglich eigentlich in
der arbeit belastet und und zeit kostet
befreien und die analogie es ist
passiert wenn man sich das anschaut weil
das internet im grunde genommen ja etwas
ähnliches liefern könnte ich kann ich
noch ein stück weiter gehen und sagen
wenn wir mal ein bisschen verrückter
denken könnte man sieht könnte man eine
anleihe an dem science-fiction-film
markt
wo es eigentlich irgendwann darum geht
dass die menschen eher in einer disco pi
also in einem horrorszenario
alle physisch in einer nährlösung liegen
das wäre also was wie ein biologisches
grundeinkommen was sie dann haben weil
sie etwa ernährt werden und ansonsten
findet das leben im geist statt und zwar
animiert eben und transportiert über
eine technologie wo wir alles erleben
können wo wir miteinander agieren können
in einer virtuellen realität dieser
dieser universellen idealen maschine
wohl nichts mehr etwas kostet wo wir
auch nicht mehr um gerechtigkeit kämpfen
müssen um haben oder sein kämpfen
sondern wir haben alles und sind alles
im sind glücklich dann sind wirklich
dabei heran der matrix ist das trennen
die die philosophen die amerikanischen
analytischen sagen bleib ich dann brain
dass dort das gehirn in den haaren sein
könnte man sich philosophisch aber schon
fragen ob das so schlimm ist weil
philosophisch gesehen wissen wir eh
nicht was die realität ist ob es nur so
gehirn impulse sind würden sie es nicht
so gut finden wenn wir nur gehirn im
tank sind ehrlich gesagt wäre mir das
komplett egal also wenn ich jetzt mit
ihnen also sie sind ein gehirn der tank
und ich bin gern im tank ja und wir sind
sozusagen über eine nährlösung und ein
neuronales netz über das internet
miteinander verbunden und es fühlt sich
so an wie es sich jetzt anfühlt das wird
doch komplett egal ich würde gerne
wissen wie es sich anfühlt wenn ich
nachher mit dem mittagessen gehen ja
dann sind wir immer noch zwei gehirne im
tank aber wir wir haben sozusagen die
simulation eines gemeinsamen
mittagessens mit der simulation von
erinnerten neuronalen reizen die
geschmacksnerven aktivieren können wo
ich das gefühl habe ich es weiß ich
nicht gipfel oder ich es was immer mit
ihnen nachher und wenn sich das alles so
anfühlen würde dann wäre das toll es
gibt ja wunderbarer philosophische
überlegungen dazu ob wir nicht längst
alle in einer simulation leben ich habe
mich damit mal sehr lange beschäftigt
als ich ein sabbatical nato das ist
wirklich großartig weil sie irgendwann
das gefühl habe ich muss erstmal raus
gehen in eine bar und ein bier trinken
weil ich werde sonst auch ein bisschen
nervös konnten sie nachweisen dass sie
nicht wieder lösen selber beweisen dass
ich nicht in der lösung schwimme oder
jedenfalls die lösung war so gut dass
der negative nachweis nicht gelungen ich
bin begeistert weil ich sehe dass ein
bisschen ähnlich sie sind aber der erste
gesprächspartner partnerin die
bestätigen sagt das ist mir egal
die meisten sagen und auch in
philosophischen texten die enden hessen
sind der conclusio das wehr und bliebe
eine horror vision würden sie sich an
die maschine anschließen wenn sie
wüssten die es nachher so perfekt dass
sie noch viel schönes erleben können als
die eh schon erleben
also nochmal einmal das ist wirklich der
spannendste punkt glaube ich der die
entscheidende frage ist können wir den
unterschied machen und die die die
moralische oder ethische bewertung dass
es eine horror version version wäre wenn
wir vor vision wäre wenn wir so
zusammenleben würden als gehirn im tank
stammt ja daher dass ich eigentlich den
unterschied machen können muss wenn ich
dann aber nicht mehr machen kann dann
kann es keine horror vision sein dann
ist es einfach eine andere form der
umsetzung unseres lebens und unseres
glücks oder unglücks zustands und dann
kann ich sagen warum soll ich das nicht
machen
ich bin begeistert von dieser offenheit
für die nährlösung und dass wir dorthin
schwimmen das ist uns ab jetzt noch egal
weil es fühlt sich nicht so an her
können wir bestellt ist sich ein
richtiges gespräch an ist auch eines und
in dem gespräch möchte ich jetzt zudem
gehen was ich glaube als ihre
hauptthemen sind der letzten jahre
identifiziert heraus gefehlt dazu haben
und das ist nicht dramatisieren sie
sagen dann noch das okay so ein bisschen
habe ich das gefühl sie sehen das
internet und die ganze digitale welt mit
ihren faszinierenden möglichkeiten als
süßes gift ist es irgendwie toll und wir
fühlen uns gut dabei und es macht uns er
nie fröhlicher besser
entspannter aber es ist auch irgendwie
gift ja es ist ein süßes gift was da vor
uns liegt mit dem internet unter der der
technologie
das liegt aber nicht in der technologie
sondern das liegt in uns das gift
es gibt einen schönen satz von fernen
dzemski ein linker kulturkritiker der
mal gesagt hat wo große linguist und
großer linguist genau technologies 11 is
basically net technologie ist eigentlich
erst mal neutral
die frage ist dann was macht der mensch
mit ihren technologie macht nicht selbst
ja auch roboter machen nicht selbst
programmieren die und dann machen sie
was algorithmen machen nicht selbst
menschen schreiben diese algorithmen
dann machen sie was also süßes gift ist
hier oder hier oder wo immer sie es
verordnen wollen und nicht in der
technologie das ist das ist glaube ich
der wesentliche unterschied das heißt
wir haben im grunde in der technologie
einen einen trigger eine eine fall ein
verstärker der es uns möglich macht
menschliche vielleicht er manchmal
problematische eigenschaften zu
verstärken und zu bedienen so dass wir
so sein opfer unserer eigenen vorzüge
werden im englischen sagt man
convenience also die gemütlichkeit ja
die bequemlichkeit vielleicht besser ist
etwas was alles schlägt kann man am
besten am beispiel datenschutz versus
informationelle selbstbestimmung
deutlich machen wenn sie das thema
diskutieren sagt ihnen jeder mir ist
mein datenschutz verteidigt ich ja ich
gebe meine daten nicht frage ich möchte
dass sie geschützt sind
solange sie aber anfangen sie möchten
dann liegt bei itunes runterladen sie
möchten ein buch bei amazon kaufen sie
möchten bei facebook was posten und
kriegen dann eine disclaimer also eine
datenschutz regelung die länger ist als
die verfassung der vereinigten staaten
und sollen die lese ich niemand isst
dann klingt ja zack weg egal hauptsache
krieg jetzt den song hauptsache ich
krieg das buch das ist die convenience
die bequemlichkeit wie das süße gift ist
mit uns unsere faulheit führt uns in
diese gefährliche faulheit würde ich
nicht sagen bequemlichkeit um ein
bisschen zu zeigen wie süß das gift
wie sich die technologie noch unbewertet
ist habe ich ja noch ein youtube
werbevideo mitgebracht das microsoft
veröffentlicht über jahre neues produkt
das hugo lentz heißt dreidimensionale
dinge projizieren uns die jetzt
problemlos in den raum das schauen wir
uns doch mal an die hand gegeben sondern
ein bisschen was in unsere wohnungen
kommt also der bildschirm ist schon dort
wo ich ihn haben will der fliegt dann in
der oben
und jetzt hat er aber dreidimensionale
modelle die sind jetzt noch nicht so
machen sie nicht aus damals ist auch
noch nicht besser aber jetzt kann man
sagen frau merkel kreativen
möglichkeiten sind gsteiger wer kann das
modul hat schöner machen alles früher ja
nationen hissen gesteigert und auch hier
wieder bequemlichkeit ist es sehr viel
einfacher beispielsweise im innendesign
in der architektur im produktdesign in
der gestaltung von auto innenräumen und
so weiter oder auch von ganzen
automodellen damit umzugehen weil man
weil man selber 360° sich im innen- und
um den gegenstand bewegen kann und ein
dreidimensionales mit
also habe ich getestet
das ist ich fand es faszinierend ich
habe die getestet oder gar nicht so
lange her und habe zum beispiel so
formen geschaffen und sie können denn
sie sind dann am dunklen raum und sie
können mit ihren händen können sie so
leuchtenden geometrische formen schaffen
die sie dann mit der hand hoch werfen
können wie bälle und so es ist wirklich
ein 1 1 in dem moment auch tatsächlich
ein kreativer prozess ist fühlt sich
großartig an so etwas einfach machen zu
können und das andere was ich
ausprobiert habe ist eine eine
schiffschaukel über münchen wo ich sagen
muss ich musste mich an dem mann der
diese dieses diese software entwickelt
da muss ich mich dass zeiten wollen wir
auch bei der ich das ergebnis aber wie
auf der kirmes tatsächlich nicht möglich
doch angst dabei ist natürlich schon
irre wie man sich dann in eine welt
wahrnehmung reinversetzen kann stichwort
wie merkt man den unterschied
die durch solche brillen möglich ist
auch sie finden das gut weil a priori da
freuen sie sich auf noch mehr von
solchen stunt ich finde das erst mal
sie nicht interessant ich glaube dass
das ganz neue einsatzbereiche vermittelt
es wird auch einsatzbereiche entwickeln
und vermitteln mit denen wir uns dann
wieder kritisch auseinandersetzen aber
ist es die zukunft kommt dass lvb das
schon also ich war jetzt kürzlich im
silicon valley mal habt ihr eine ganze
reihe von großen it unternehmen von
startups angeschaut und es gibt kein
thema was alle so umtreibt was
vergleichbar wichtig wäre wie die
virtuelle realität auch was
investitionsstrategien angeht da wird
richtig viel geld investiert da wird
entwickelt entwickelt entwickelt und
glaube da passiert der nächste große
schritt auch eben von solchen industrien
wie wie der pornoindustrie zum beispiel
wenn sie sich vorstellen dass sie mit
mit diesen brillen also demnächst weiß
nicht wer für sie spannend ist nehmen
wir mal an charlie napoli zum beispiel
mit deckeln sie sex haben wir können sie
ins auge schauen die können sie berühren
das kann dann über über sensorik am 12
die haben ja natürlich ja aber man kann
ja dann sich das auswählen was man will
aber faszinierend ist das für viele oder
ich würde sagen fliegen über die ferne
oder die victoria falls noch wie das
matterhorn etwas gibt legen das gibt es
schon eher ja also kann faszinierend das
zeugs und nicht trotzdem vielleicht
sagen sie gerade darum lassen wir uns
einlullen
in einer situation wo wir eben die die
packungsbeilage überhaupt nicht mehr
lesen
und da fand ich eine textstelle in einem
ihrer texte wo sie sagen der mensch der
digital vernetzte mensch wird wieder zum
nazis also in der griechischen
mythologie der sohn dieses fluss gottes
der sich theresa sohn schaut sich hat
haben sein eigenes spiegelbildern warum
wird der mensch wieder zum nazis also
ich glaube jeder mensch ist irgendwie
auch ein einsatz ist ganz ohne geht es
wahrscheinlich ohne selbst liebe ist man
in der welt ja letztlich nicht nicht
überlebensfähig aber die die
narzisstische eigenschaft des menschen
wird über das internet schon stark
gesteigert weil sie im grunde genommen
ja
wirklich wie in einem spiegel schauen
wir haben einfach über die echo kammer
gesprochen oder auch den echo bunker in
dem wir irgendwann sitzen wenn wir nur
noch sozusagen die eigene meinung
zurückgespiegelt bekommen
das ist eine so eine weltsicht also form
von welt kurzsichtigkeit habe ich das
mal genannt weil man eben das eigene
bild die eigene wahrnehmung der welt
immer größer sieht und das was andere
sehen oder alternative positionen werden
immer kleiner werden immer stärker an
den rand gedrückt und das hat natürlich
eine starke narzisstische komponente sie
nutzen die metapher ja ziemlich präzis
weil sie haben drei versionen was
passiert was wenn wir uns daran erinnern
ich musste auch noch mal nach blättern
und lesen dann was passiert genau mit
dem nazis im mythos und was ist die
analogie zu halten hat in der nazis ist
ja so verliebt in das bild was er von
sich selbst auf also nazis selber ist so
verliebt in das bild was er von sich
selbst auf der glatten wasseroberfläche
sieht dass er sich herunter beugt um
sein ebenbild zu küssen und dabei dann
in den see gestürzt und ertrinkt dass
die eine version daher bringt der und
dann sagen sie es gibt aber andere
versionen wo er nur da fällt ein blatt
ins bild und dann ist verzerrt das bild
unter sieht das eher hässlich ist ist
das ertrinken wir oder erschaudern wir
ob der hässlichkeit wenn wir geld genug
hat uns damit den sind mit mit einer
entsprechenden portion autosuggestion
und der der schönen glatten oberfläche
die man natürlich herstellen kann in
in der filter blase oder in der echo
kann können wir schon ertrinken also wer
sich wirklich nur darauf fokussiert kann
ertrinken
ich glaube dass wir brauchen mehr
blätter um es mal so zu sagen ja also
wir brauchen die die dinge ob es blätter
sind irgendwas was reinfällt was die die
oberfläche tatsächlich irritiert in
ihrer glatt haid stört und damit zeigt
das eben das bild nicht immer so sein
kann sondern dass es andere bilder gibt
eine andere wahrnehmung gibt das wäre
was was es wird meint mein lieblings
begriff was man im amerikanischen
erzählen dpd bezeichnet die begegnung
mit die ungeplante begegnung mit dem
überraschenden anderen wo wir uns
auseinandersetzen
dadurch dass wir in gesprächen mit den
menschen in der begegnung auch in etwas
was wir lesen oder wahrnehmen
plötzlich eine ganz andere sicht auf die
dinge kriegen und auch auf uns selbst ja
häufig wo man dann eben den anderen
spiegel vorgehalten bekommen denken gut
okay ganz so platt ist die oberfläche
nicht dann wird es eigentlich auch es
interessant glatte oberflächen beim
menschen sind ja komplett uninteressant
in vielerlei hinsicht und dann hat man
die chance eben auch was auszubilden wie
toleranz wie eine eine perspektive
erweiterung man kann man nur lernen wenn
sie immer nur auf die glatte oberfläche
schauen und sich selber sehen lernen sie
nichts mehr
und das ist für für das ist dann sehr
langweilig und auch nicht gut seriendieb
igate ich habe nachgeschaut das findet
beim aber kennt kein mensch auf deutsch
und dann wird angegeben
es hieß ja auch zum beispiel
mehr glück als verstand haben eben zeigt
was man gar nicht berechnet habe und es
gibt zwar nicht das stimmt nicht
also hsv der der der die server in lippe
die als als konzept sozusagen entdeckt
und erfunden hat hat dadurch das
operativ so so abwertend bei einer
stetig auch nicht schlecht mal mehr
glück als verstand weil manchmal also es
ist eigentlich
man könnte auch sagen intendierte
serendipity ist etwas also mann mann
mann befreit sich man macht sich auf die
suche ist aber dabei offen für
überraschung und sucht nicht nur das was
man zu finden weiß das ist im grunde
genommen
die mischung aus den vorzügen des
internet und aus anderen impulsen und
begegnungen mit denen wir eben den
horizont dann auch einmal an dem was wir
die richtige welt nennen hollywood hat
ein bunt so wenn man das mal auch nicht
max gebe ich jetzt so ein bisschen diese
romanzen diese romantischen komödie wenn
wir das mag an wunderbaren film gemacht
seinen dpt die heldinnen junge schöne
heldin trifft einen jungen schönen man
weiß aber nicht ob das was werden soll
dann schreibt sie in ein buch ihren
namen erkennt den namen noch nicht gibt
das buch hinein ob die qualitat und sagt
wenn das buch je wieder zu dir kommt und
gewinn ist meinen namen
dann wollen wir uns treffen und sonst
hat das schicksal uns nicht zusammen
gehen mich gibt's hatten sich ja so was
erlebt dass ein geduldet volland ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob man nicht
gelegentlich in solchen situationen sich
als mensch bemüßigt fühlt dem zufall
etwas nachzuhelfen dass es kann ja auch
mal gut sein
sowas hatte ich selber nicht erlebt aber
es gibt tatsächlich begegnungen gibt
passieren die komplett aus dem nichts
kommen und die am meisten nach hallen in
der erinnerung also dass ich auch
menschliche begegne ich weiß dass ich
mal eine autobahn abgefahren bin um was
zu essen weil ich zum hunger hatte in
tirol in österreich und setzte mich in
einem gartenrestaurant dann kam eine
wirklich sehr alte frau zwar alle tische
waren frei und diese alte frau kam zu
machen sagt kann ich mich zu ihnen
setzen
und ich weiß ein bisschen bisschen
genervt tatsächlich dachte ich wenn ich
meine ruhe haben und dann hat sie gesagt
sie brauchen jetzt ganz so genau gucken
ich möchte mich nur hinsetzen und dann
habe ich gedacht jahre zu setzen sie
sich doch dann haben wir dreieinhalb
vier stunden zusammen
dessen was gegessen und über das leben
geredet und das war in den letzten 10 20
jahren die die nachhaltigste begegnen
die ich hatte
weil das war einfach so eine
interessante lebensgeschichte dass ganz
viele punkte entstanden sind im gespräch
wo ich für mich selber angeknüpft habe
gedacht habe ich muss noch mal über
etwas nachdenken
viele würden dagegen halten okay bei
begegnungen mit menschen die nicht mein
partner meine partnerin der wichtigste
mensch im leben werden sollen lassen wir
es auf die gartenbeiz wie man bei uns
sagt ankommen bei der partnersuche sei
das ein riesenvorteil das internet dass
man da hunderte von kriterien abgleichen
kann und ich weiß sie haben aus
professionellen gründen sie beschreiben
dass das wirklich mal durchgezogen ob
das was bringt partnersuche gibt halt
was ist herausgekommen
ich fand den prozent erst mal
interessant was für kriterien abgefragt
werden man muss dann irgendwie farbliche
innenausstattung von räumen gut oder
schlecht finden und autos gut oder
schlecht finden also ich glaube dass das
es schon so ist dass das matchmaking
also zusammenführen was passend ist
erfolgsversprechend sein kann aber gibt
es übrigens auch studien zu inzwischen
nur auf der kurzen strecke
das heißt so für zwei drei jahre
vielleicht ist also weniger funktioniert
super und man hat das gefühl man hat
sozusagen den nicht partner in crime
sondern denen den partner im geiste und
auch ansonsten gefunden
auf die lange strecke hin funktion jetzt
nicht und meine persönliche erfahrung
ist tatsächlich auch das dass das was
nicht zusammenpasst oft ja sozusagen die
entspannungsraum dann definiert aus dem
sich gespräche auseinandersetzung aus
handlungen von von lebens wünschen
von alltagsgestaltung ergeben so dass
ich das relativ einleuchtend finde also
wo alles passt ist ja auch dann ist es
auch relativ schnell langweilig dann
aber weil diese algorithmen gehen also
macht dem prinzip gleich und gleich
gesellt sich wesentliche schon sie
können natürlich andere alkoholische
könnt ihr mann ambros brücken randomized
algorithmus also algorithmen wo man
sozusagen vermeintlich zufällige
entscheidungs komponenten
einprogrammiert ein schreibt kann man
machen
aber selbst wenn sie eine regel für die
berücksichtigung von zufall in einen
algorithmus schreiben ist das sozusagen
letzten effekt keine zufällige
entwicklung sonst ist eine eine
determinierte eine idee tmn
determinierte einsatz prozess von zufall
ist auch kein zufall
aber es wird vielleicht trotzdem gehen
also ich verstehe und verstand den
gedankengang die sie schön entwickeln
wenn wir den zufall ausrechnen lassen
aus unserem leben legen wir in dieser
filter blase echo kammer meinen die welt
bestehe aus allen leuten die das gleiche
denken soll nicht gut aber man könnte
doch sagen algorithmen algorithmus
rechne mir wieder ein
eine meinung die mich ärgert das könnte
er doch machen
das stimmt aber es ist kein zufall das
ist ja eine einer entscheidung in
bestimmten abständen zum beispiel eine
ausnahme von der regel zu machen
und wenn ich sage mach vier mal in der
minute eine ausnahme von der regel ist
das eine regel war dazu wissen wir ob
das leben nicht auch so nein das wissen
bin ich wenn sie ich habe mich damit
beschäftigt für mein letztes dickeres
buch für next wenn sie in die in die
quanten für sie gehen und so dann kommen
sie da hin wo man wirklich sagt da gibt
es tatsächlich offenbar ware zufällige
entwicklungen während es ja auch im
physikalischen leben ansonsten zum
beispiel die these gibt dass jede
begegnung die einem autounfall zugelegt
also begegnung von auto und auto oder
von autor fußgänger auch letztlich eine
form von deterministische vorbestimmung
ist also da kommen wir in sehr
schwierige gefehlt und niemand wird
beweisen können jetzt den zufall als
zufall in der reinheit gibt aber sie
finden
wir das ausrechnen lassen durch die
algorithmen dann verarmen wir als
menschen
er ist kommt vielleicht darauf an in
welchem ausmaß man das tut also
natürlich habe ich auch wenn ich mich
entscheiden
eine bestimmte zeitung zu lesen zum
beispiel dann weiß ich ja auch welche
position welchem grund positionierung
hat diese zeitung ja das ist ja auch
nicht alles total überraschend was dann
konnten also politische einschätzungs
linien eines blattes kennt man in der
regel und deshalb wählt man diese
zeitung zum beispiel
aber wenn wir es im internet anschauen
haben wir dort sozusagen inzwischen die
tatsache dass das dass das ganze leben
wir auf basis von von software bei uns
immer starke organisiert wird und die
reichweite solche berechnungen ist dann
eben deutlich anders als wenn ich
bezeichnung wiese wo ich weiß welche
linie die hat aber ansonsten viele
andere dinge tun wo ich nicht erwarten
kann was passiert wir kaufen aber ein
algorithmisch wir suchen informationen
algorithmisch wir suchen den partner
algorithmisch wir lassen uns demnächst
restaurants empfehlen wo wir bestimmte
menschen zu einem bestimmten zeit
treffen können weil die analyse unserer
bewegungsprofile anhand von handy und
kauf daten und sagt wenn sie den
dunkelhaarigen 40 jährigen mit und ohne
kinder in der wg leben suchen dann
müssten sie bitte weiß ich nicht
irgendwie heute abend ins ins theater
gehen und zwar am besten zwischen 19 uhr
und 21 30 oder so dass das ist alles
möglich mit und bekommen jetzt mache ich
allfälligen facebook freunde da rein die
geben wir dann tipps sagen ließ das auch
mal das buch ist es eine bereicherung
oder rechnen sie das auch zu den echo
kamera freunden
das ist natürlich schon eine
bereicherung weil das so zumindest
sozusagen mal meine individuelle
präferenz in ein soziales gefüge setzt
und mir andere kontaktpunkte bietet aber
in der regel suchen natürlich freunde
nicht danach aus dass sie möglichst
anders sind und möglichst entfernt mit
ihren mahnungen von uns sondern es gibt
ja schon sozusagen eine gedankliche und
gefühls community die in der
freundschaft sozusagen dann belebt wird
und das heißt ich krieg da nicht den
wahren überraschungseffekt aber ich
krieg zumindest andere andere
berührungspunkte mit anderen themen und
einschätzungen der echte
überraschungseffekt ergibt sich dann
wenn man wirklich in reality check
machten geht man in ganz anderen bereich
liest was ganz anderes geht ein ganz
anderes auto wo ansonsten
sie sind ja auch als forscherin dann
haben sie gesagt unterwegs im silicon
valley dem ort wo diese menschen wie
larry page der google erfinder jeff
bezos der jetzt milliarden hat als
techno unternehmer all diese leute mark
zuckerberg facebook besitzt so wohnen
und arbeiten was was wollen was haben
die auf dem radar wollen die die welt
verändern wollen die zu den herrschern
dieser welt werden was wollen diese
silicon valley herrscher ich glaube dass
es schon einige gibt die die welt
verändern wollen und dabei durchaus
positive ambitionen haben wenn man sich
anschaut was google
so entfällt der der lebensverlängerung
das bewegungsform stimmen krankheiten
und so weiter dann gibt es da schon eine
menge dinge auch wenn wir jetzt das
ganze thema selbst fahren das auto
anschauen aber also lebensverlängerung
das endet vielleicht als hirne im tank
wie lange wird er wird unser programm
hochgeladen auf eine maschine möchten
sie so was ein ewig werden wir daher
denken und noch ein bisschen reden ja
das weiß ich nicht also irgendwann ist
so ein thema hier auch erschöpft dass
das weiß ich nicht ich bin auch nicht
sicher ob wir wirklich irgendwann dahin
kommen also es gibt ja schon auch
tatsächlich physiologische und
machbarkeit grenzen
diese wieso nicht die elektronisch
weiter existieren gibt es geht hier
haben wir ja steve page jobs zuckerberg
besser
diese leute haben schon sehr strahlende
techno fantasieren genau und sie haben
dabei schon auch den den aspekt der
convenience der der bequemlichkeit im
sinne mit mit ganz viel modernen
entwicklungen die auch gut wenn ich mir
vorstelle was das selbstfahrende autos
zum beispiel mit unserer gesellschaft
machen kann was ein ein system von
individualisierten öffentlichen
nahverkehr angeht ja also ich gehe hier
ist im studio gleich raus dann kommt der
selbstfahrende das selbst war lauter
angefahren fährt mich zum flughafen das
muss hier nicht parken das muss nicht in
der innenstadt vielleicht packen es muss
auch am flughafen nicht packen das kann
alles außerhalb passieren das geht alles
on demand über das handy und wir haben
sozusagen die ganze
sie war der taxifahrer wäre sie in
dieser realität nach jetzt zum flughafen
fahren wird er bedauert dass das ist
richtig müssen wir mitleid haben mit ihm
oder ich glaube es gibt bestimmte formen
von diskutieren entwicklungen in der
technologie die sich nicht einschränken
lassen das ja die diskussion die wir bei
google in konkurrenz zum regulären taxi
auch schon gehabt habe
und ehrlich gesagt ich glaube dass es
schon wichtig ist dass wir innovative
impulse bekommen und dass man sich die
frage stellt ist das was wir aktuell
machen auch wenn wir uns daran gewöhnt
haben eigentlich immer dass das richtige
oder gar das beste und der mensch ist
darauf gerichtet sich zu entwickeln und
dann muss er sich auch damit
auseinandersetzen dass dann irgendwann
sich verändern sich was verändert also
bei aller kritik die sie in ihren
geschäften bücher neuss und jetzt ist
endgültig deutlich geworden sie sind
keine maschinen digital maschinen
stürmerin überhaupt nicht machen sie
sich trotzdem oder anstatt überlegungen
dass zu viel macht dann bei jobs und
bessers und so gelangt ist also was mich
erstmal umtreibt ist die frage ist es
tatsächlich allein eine entwicklung von
geschäftsmodellen einer entwicklung von
innovativen technologien und lebens oder
oder existenz verbesserungen mit all den
wirtschaftlichen potenzialen die
dahinter liegen oder ist es auch eine
form von religion und wenn man das
silicon valley anguckt kann man schon
sein gibt es ein paar elemente die sowas
wie wie technologie als als neue
religiöse lebensform interpretieren das
beginnt von der inszenierung von neuen
produkten wie sie steve jobs ja wirklich
sehr beeindruckend gemacht hat aber das
war so was wie ein erschaffung smid das
ja sie als kinder aus ja und dann kommt
jetzt hier kommt nicht der apfel oder
auch nicht die welt
am siebten tag es kommt das neue iphone
aber es hat eine ähnliche ähnliche
komponente in der darstellung und die
die art der der beschwörung des
individuellen einsatzes wo arbeit
eigentlich das leben ist und wo man auf
dem auf dem google campus leben kann und
wo die versorgung dort stattfindet und
wo mit den unternehmens bussen die
menschen dorthin gebracht wenn es hat
schon so was von einer von einer
community die man wenn man böse sein
will als auch eine form von sekte
bezeichnen kann und da denke ich
manchmal da da haben wir schon eine
entwicklung wo man sieht das denken geht
in eine form der religiösität wo ich
glaube da macht es abzusehen mal durch
zu rütteln zu sagen stopp mein mann
schwingt vielleicht auch noch diesseits
der sekten atmosphäre dieser
amerikanische grundzug mit man kann
zwischen gut und böse unterscheiden wir
wissen was das gute ist jetzt muss man
es nur noch machen
finden sie dass die amerikaner das ist
das meer ich finde gott existiert in den
usa noch bei allen also im sinne von man
weiß noch was to make the world a better
place wir wollen die welt verbessern
also jeder sagt das ja in jedem
bewerbungsgespräch jeder taxichauffeur
will die welt verbessern und so also
diese sei diese klarheit die ich zum
teil auch bewundernswert finde wir wir
sagen hier gut hier schlecht machen mal
was hab das nicht also ich habe mein
erstes gefühl dass wir eigentlich näher
dran sind an dieser kategorischen
unterscheidung von gut und schlecht was
ist richtig und was ist falsch und dass
das in usa gerade was so was so
technologische entwicklung angeht
deutlich offener stattfindet als bei uns
und das auch sozusagen auf dem weg dahin
dass das fehler machen leichter ist viel
leichter ist als bei uns mit mit
einschränkungen ja wenn ich so ein
begriff start up kultur in im silicon
valley verfassten vorwort ja mach bitte
die fehler schnell damit wir weiter
kommst und macht sie nach vorne
gerichtet auf die zukunft hin gerichtet
dann muss ich ein bisschen schmunzeln
weil sozusagen auch im scheitern es gibt
das gute und das schlechte scheint so
könnte man das unterscheiden trotzdem
ist die grundhaltung natürlich die man
darf fehler machen und das ist ein
lernprozess wieder zu machen dann kommt
man ein stück weiter hat mehr erfahrung
bei uns macht man fehler
man ist gescheitert und ist raus aus dem
geschäft das
ein bisschen zugespitzt der der
unterschied weshalb wir eben auch an
manchen stellen dann nicht so
erfolgreich sind in technologischen
fortschritten wie das in den usa der
fall wo ihre these gewiss stimmt dass
wir in europa manchmal sehr sicher sind
was gut und was schlecht ist ist zum
beispiel bei der präsidentschaftswahl
die kommt da denken ja alle
europäerinnen und europäer hoffentlich
hillary clinton und sicher nicht donald
trump wir denken jetzt vielleicht auch
kann man sagen diese neuen sozialen
medien die beherrscht der donald trump
ja wie ein meister und magier also ist
auch eine gefahr in diesen medien dass
der der populist deren talent dafür hat
das ruchlos ausnutzen kann
klar also da haben wir die schleife zum
beginn unseres gesprächs das ist
natürlich die möglichkeit jeder hat die
chance sein eigenes agenda setting zu
betreiben seine eigenen kampagnen zu
fahren seine eigenen schützt uns
auszulösen das ist dass das kann man
individuell heute machen das war früher
anders als es sozusagen immer dazwischen
stufe eines mediums bedurfte um in die
öffentlichkeit zu geraten
und das macht doch schon großartig
materie überhaupt nicht gut obwohl sie
die erfahrung im letzten wahlkampf
gemacht hat wie wichtig das ist damit
hat obama gewonnen mit dem einsatz von
sozialen medien sie es ich denke oft
dass es eine form von berührungsangst
ist auch eine form von mangelnder
bewegung wirklich an die menschen
heranzukommen den menschen nahe zu
kommen sich auch nahe war zu zeigen
aber ich denke das schafft auch wenn ich
das beobachte ich noch mal das gefühl
vielleicht wird er tatsächlich gewählt
und dann erleben wir einen tag wo wir
auf einen knopfdruck er auftritt und
sagt so jetzt können wir das schauspiel
beenden und jetzt zur euro politik
wo ist also ich kann einfach nicht
glauben dass das das wirklich
realistisch ist wie wie dieser mann
auftritt
und wenn wir irgendwann sozusagen
erleben den moment wo er das ganze als
eine perfekte inszenierung des des
rabiaten rumpelnden
präsidentschaftskandidaten erleben dann
wäre ich nicht richtig überrascht es
könnte sich vorstellen dass streift er
dann wie eine schlangenhaut wieder ab
und dessen business
ich hatte es sogar nachgedacht weil
irgendwie ist es ist so unfassbar
seltsam an vielen stellen auch dass der
dafür so viel zustimmung bekommt ist
schon auch eine schleife zum anfang das
hat wieder mit den wutbürgern sicher zu
tun leute die sich die sich abgekoppelt
verein brutal abgekoppelt für und sagen
nicht weil irgendein der mir da ein
bisschen mut macht also nicht fürs
establishment stehen ist natürlich
lustig ist weil weil trump natürlich
eigentlich ein teil der der das new
yorker kapitalismus ist wie er im buche
steht und trotzdem gehört hillary
clinton als als zugehörig zu einer der
beiden großen dynastien die die politik
in den usa in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten geprägt haben eben ganz
stark zum establishment und das ist aus
meiner sicht ein problem mit dem sie
umgehen sie haben als
kommunikationsprofi schon analysiert das
ist schon fast die schleife die man
gerne einmal ende eines gespräches habe
ich mache noch eine kleine schleife
drüber eine
auch ein bisschen persönliche weil sie
schreiben ja auch wenn wir uns fragen
was kommt gibt es einen artikel über sie
gesagt haben wir werden in zukunft nicht
mehr telefonieren sondern teleportieren
das könnte einige erschrecken da so
werden wir das
dass toni telefonen werden wir irgendwie
ein anderer hin und her denken ja ich
glaube dass wir dass wir auf dem weg
sind neue neue verbindungen zwischen
menschen computer zu entwickeln das ist
jetzt vor einigen jahren das iphone
gewesen dass eben ganz wunderbar uns den
zugang ins internet erleichtert hat das
internet mobil gemacht hat der nächste
schritt ist die sprachsteuerung die ja
schon erstaunlich funktioniert also ich
diktiere inzwischen fast alle meine e
mails
lieber herr kollege neuer zahlen neue
zeile ja das schreibt das ding also
einfach so runter und das geht viel
schneller
das wird weiterentwickelt werden und der
nächste schritt der sicherlich noch in
der zukunft liegt aber jetzt schon
möglich ist ist sozusagen die direkte
das direkte abgreifen von von hirn
signalen von neuronalen signalen durch
elektroden die aufgesetzt werden auf den
kopf oder implantate die eingepflanzt
werden in betraten wurde das geht ja
genau ist das können sie sich zuschicken
die können sich nichts zu schicken
sondern die ratten die eine ratte hat in
einem käfig in den usa gelernt dass sie
wenn ein rotes licht angeht auf eine
taste drücken muss im anschluss wasser
zu bekommen pawlowsche konditionierung
die ratte wusste irgendwann nachdem das
x-mal passiert ist licht taste wasser
dann hat man die mit dem hirn implantat
ausgelesen sozusagen hat die signale
über das internet nach nach rio de
janeiro geschickt und dort mit einem
implantat in eine andere ratte
eingepflanzt und diese andere ratte hat
im grunde genommen sofort gewusst wie
sie ans wasser kommt da gab es nämlich
kein licht im käfig das heißt es
hingegen hat die taste gedrückt und
betrunken und das ist das erste
neuronale netzwerk was etabliert
woraufhin sie das cool oder wird dass
das rad race dass unser leben ist
zuseher beschleunigen ich finde das
wissenschaftlich erstmal sehr cool ja
und es gibt ja gott sei dank ein
unterschied zwischen ratten und menschen
deshalb beobachte ich das erst noch mit
interesse aber auch in der medizinischen
forschung werden solche implantate
längst eingesetzt und damit kann man zum
beispiel computer arme also roboterarme
kann man hin und her denken das
funktioniert alles schon spannende und
vielleicht zum teil erschreckende
visionen der zukunft aber das ist die
bewertung das muss man dann ja auch
alles schauen es kann auch besser kommen
als man denkt oder befürchtet hat aber
sie haben gesagt der zauber des zufalls
soll nicht verloren gehen
ganz persönlich wo hoffen erhoffen sie
in dieser zukunft mit telepathie und
allem für sich was soll der zauber des
zufalls für sie richten was wir die sie
so richtig freuen
kein zufall dann hat der zauber des
zufalls ergibt sich immer da wo ich mir
zeit nehmen und die möglichkeit habe
etwas auf mich zukommen zu lassen was
ich nicht suchen kann das ist beim
reisen so das ist manchmal wenn man
irgendwo sitzt und ein glas wein trinkt
allein und dem gespräch kommt so und das
würde ich mir gerne erhalten es gibt
kleine dinge die da kommen wir rufen sie
noch auf eine große veränderung also
nein nein doch nicht gleich also große
dinge haben sie auch glücklich gefunden
und ich bin bin sehr glücklich und ich
freue mich mich mit dieser entwicklung
über die wm auseinandersetzen zu können
und dabei im blick halten zu können dass
man immer mal den schritt raus machen
kann um eben dem zufall die chance zu
geben
irgendwann mal ein zu treffen frau
merkel wir in tanks sind ich glaube es
nicht oder ich das gespräch habe mir
sehr gefallen ich bedanke mich dafür
herzlichen dank auch wenn meine kollegin
barbara bleisch im historischen museum
basel am nächsten sonntag mit zwei
philosophen über das erbe des großen
humanisten erasmus von rotterdam spricht
dann wird einer ihrer gäste vertreten
humanismus heiße noch heute erziehung
zur freiheit der andere aber wird unter
dem stichwort evolutionären humanismus
für eine optimierung des menschen über
die menschliche natur hinaus plädieren
und wenn sie gärten liegen sowie den
gedanken dass ein garten ein psychogramm
seiner besitzer ist dann empfehle ich
ihnen den film gnadenlos der finnischen
filmemacherin wird subari jetzt gleich
anschließend in der sternstunde kunst
einen schönen sonntag
[Musik]